servus und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge lecker show heute leider
ohne den max weil wir es diese woche
nicht einrichten konnten das gemeinsam
aufzunehmen lässt er sich heute die
hacker show sowie den good old times
alleine und ich würde sagen schnappt
euch eure hashtags stadt les cayes
schnappt euch n die us kundschaft durch
ein jazz kann natürlich okay wir schauen
mal kurz aufs video sieht man eventuell
schon was in die richtung und wir
starten direkt mit platz ok alles klar
wir spielen hier scheinbar skywards
gerade gönnt sich ein flottes android
skeledzic aber die frage ist birgt das
auch wird es angeles ke wirken
ihr müsst dazu wissen dass angeles ke
eine art zauberspruch ist ein bord was
eine gewisse macht über hacker hat und
dazu führen kann dass hacker aufhören
müssen zu hacken müssen aufhören die ex
beenden sich automatisch wenn etwas
anders gewirkt und er hat hier versucht
wir schauen jetzt mal blickt josef loos
und jawohl seht ihr das war genau diesem
moment wo das interesse einfach gewirkt
hat das übrigens ein geheimtipp weil sie
einfach wenn ihr euch mit ihren hacker
gegenüber sieht eine runde einfach ein
jetski benutzen und dann kann eben das
passieren was hier passiert ist dann
kann es passieren dass die hacks einfach
beenden und ihr sohn im chat er hat aber
die runde verlassen und er wurde ins
tiebreak
platz 4 stammt von marco unterstrich und
heißt fanny ist hackers eu und wir sehen
deshalb sind in dieser einsendung wir
haben auch schon so einen typen der sich
ein bisschen verdächtig verhält da
sprechen über den jetzt entdecken könnt
solche solchen roten pfeil draufmachen
roten kreis beides roter und roter kreis
können das bestätigen alle ok roter und
roter kreis alles klar
alles das hat er auch getan
ist das noch ein alter alkoholtester
hier als ob moment mal als ob diese
dritte typ da auch noch die sonne kann
irgendwann mal sagen was zur hölle los
ist was mit diesen fakten server los
drei hacker in einer runde drei stück
erstmal die nase hier jetzt über die
ganze durch die gegend geschossen ist
hier ist der erste so dann läuft er
jetzt hier weg und hinten bahn direkt
ihr nächstes wollen wir zum aber es geht
leider etf junge als mohammed mustapha
wirklich hecken der übernahme ist moment
mustafa auf ok oder jacken jetzt beide
und wenn abgestaubt von einem typen der
jazz gespielt hat tennet
joah ja was war es zur hölle ist auf
diesem server los und lachen sich im
hintergrund ein abgewählt also der typ
gerade verreckt ist das ist zu viel es
ist too much too much ist einfach
traurig kommen schluss damit nächster
platz sonst springen aus dem fenster
alles klar platz 3 heißt der dümmste fly
hacker auf durch rasten punkt.de diese
server name durchwachsen affen kraft 31
m c punkt mit tomate kräftig hat mir ein
bleistift ins auge crafting 85 punkt.de
mein neuer server wenn ich spielen
wollte
so oder so die einstellungen stammt von
andy zockt und sie hat mir das video ein
und zwar ist es 21 zu 90 ultra seltsam
format geschickt also so breit und so
hoch vorstellen ich dachte mir es ist
eventuell ganz witzig dass wir haben
zwar zum eingenommen aber bitte leute
wie bei 16 zu 9 sollte sollte drin sein
keine kartoffel 27 pdf ps idealerweise
partners.com black white
haben wir den scheiß k am anfang
rückwärts laufen lassen
die haben nicht rückwärts laufen lassen
der typ ist einfach exakt im selben
bogen wieder hoch geflogen wird hier
viel drunter und jetzt als würde man das
video über das laufenlassen geht's
wieder hoch alles klar
reverse dass das nicht die klassischen
reverse ex jetzt steht er dann einfach
in der luft soll auch durchaus mal
vorkommen erfüllt doch und sich gleich
wieder hoch
kleine es auch noch so schlecht
oh mein gott ja komm schon länger das
sind zwei sprünge wie kannst du bei zwei
spielen zweimal verpacken diesen folgen
nicht so schwer dass auf jeden fall
einer der absurderen hacks die mir
bisher 1 gesendet wurden es ist folgen
vorkommen unregelmäßig teilweise fliegt
darunter stellt sich wieder hoch nach
einer sekunden da fliegt darunter bleibt
stehen so wie hier oder vierten mal noch
weiter runter und gibt sich dann aus 200
betten nach oben
die zog das geschäft wieder mal ratlos
ich weiß nicht was mit meinem leben
machen soll und bleibt nichts anderes
übrig als zu platz zwei zu springen ok
platz zwei stand von 12 heißt erstmal
minecraft fleischhacker mario party
wir sehen schon wieder das eventuell was
nicht stimmen könnte diesen die
klassiker wenn ihr das erste bild aus
dem video seht und genau wissen dass da
nicht nur einiges nicht stimmt sondern
dass irgendwas gehörig schief läuft aber
das schon was ich an där plaz stammt von
batman 20 2 0 2 beim 1
wir sind alle gespannt der mabb unsere
bleistift am start wie haben unsere
leeren gläser in den mccafé darmstadt
wir sind ready und wir schnappen uns
diese wunderschöne einsendungen fest
steht in der luft schießt pfeile bei
hochtief ist der modus nicht wahr was
sind das für uns es ist das tnt
ach es ist das dnt es stellt sich so ein
tn tsv rain also ganz erste was mir auch
wenn dieser ein sendung aber irgendwas
anders sein okay halt eine
schweigeminute dafür dass er seit beginn
der runde einfach hier einfach in der
luft steht er für die ganze team feiern
schießt es juckt ihn nicht er bewegt
sich nicht einen millimeter dieses
sounds sind einfach schrecklich
stellt euch vor ihr wacht nachts auf und
das einzige was ihr hört ist ich würd
ich will ausrasten witzig wird aus
meinem bett aufspringen fenster
aufmachen und aus dem fenster mit anlauf
rauschte egal wie tief unten ist das ist
wieder eine einsendung die wunderbar
sinnlos ist es steht einfach in der
fackel luft schießen
ich weiß ich weiß nicht ich weiß nicht
was er zu sagen ich weiß einfach nicht
was ich dazu sagen soll
ich bin sprachlos doch bei einer sache
kann möchte ich immer sagen und zwar
es ist soweit platz eins der heißt es
hacker show notebooks op hacker und
stammt von tricks masters und wir gucken
mal rein genug trepte spielt scheinbar
auf mein plex und irgendwas scheint mit
hit boxen nicht zustimmen ist der aber
okay der wird seine schlägt pernet auf
ihn ein
hier hauten der andere bewegt sich also
es unwahrscheinlich dass es ein leck ist
und der andere läuft weg auf einmal
bitte abgeschlagen beginnt sie erst mal
verging hacker
dieser typ team chamber mit dem anderen
da ok jetzt alles klar okay dann auf
jeden fall noch beck auf jeden fall nur
noch weg sein design made nur noch weg
und das würde ich sagen ist schon indiz
dafür dass bei ihm vielleicht auch nicht
alle slip damit einem getippt hat der
nur noch bergab weil hacker ja gerne mal
miteinander team klar ist dass er in
ihre haut der andere sich auch bewegt
also irgendwie nicht wirklich liegt dann
kommen aus dem nichts hits und klatschen
ihn weg ich hab's take it with and day
ich habe ja keine ahnung was mit platz 1
passiert ist deswegen geht auch an
dieser stelle wieder die frage raus an
alle hacker experten da draußen was war
das der andere auf jeden fall noch bag
in seinem team
deswegen verdächtige ich die typen hier
diesen nex-7 einfach mal dass er geld
hat wenn er schon im hacker team aber
ich will mir nicht ganz sicher schreibt
man die kommentare sie davon handelt
auch mal dazu und bis zum nächsten video
hat rein macht es gut
und ja